26 September Sabotage Angriff auf die
pipelines-nordstream 1 und 2 Deutschland
bekommt Endgültigkeit russisches Gas
mehr 8 Oktober Angriff auf die Bahn im
Norden Deutschlands bricht der komplette
Zugverkehr zusammen unbekannte hatten
zwei Kabel durchtrennt ist Deutschlands
kritische Infrastruktur ein zu leichtes
Angriffsziel mit der Isolier könnte man
das sicherlich einfach so klappen wir
waren schon alle überrascht dass
Infrastruktur angegriffen wird und es
ist auch offensichtlich geworden dass
wir da scheinbar nicht drauf vorbereitet
sind
hat das die Entscheider aufgerüttelt tun
wir jetzt genug um uns zu schützen
und wie gut sind wir auf den Worst Case
vorbereitet
die Preise gehen wenn so langsam die
Panik losgeht
wo es dann in Richtung Plünderung geht
[Musik]
Politik war unterwegs mit der
Bundespolizei Heiko tägert und seine
Kollegen sind für den Schutz der
Schienen und Bahnhöfe zuständig der
Angriff auf die Bahn hat ihn geschockt
aber nicht überrascht seit 2019 ist
tagaz Vorsitzender der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft er weiß was
seine Kolleginnen und Kollegen leisten
können und was nicht
das was wir jetzt gerade machen das
müsste die Bundespolizei viel öfter
machen können das auch von einem
revieraus mal eine präventivstreife
gefahren werden kann und zu schauen ob
dort die die Gleise in Ordnung sind ob
dort irgendjemand versucht hat an den
Gleisen zu manipulieren mit dem
derzeitigen Personal ist ein auch nur
einigermaßen angemessener Schutz für ihn
schlicht unmöglich das ist ja genau das
was ich was sie Frau Ministerin ja auch
abgefordert habe dort darauf zu achten
und dementsprechend das Personal zu
erhöhen für die für die Bahnpolizei
damit wir auch wieder diese diese
präventivstreifen fahren können momentan
ist das an den Schwerpunkt dienen
Stellen an den Schwerpunkt waren gar
nicht möglich gar nicht möglich nein
aktuell nein trotzdem der aktuellen
Situation
ein Großteil der Bahngleise ist komplett
ungeschützt
Herr Tickets wenn man das hier zieht wir
können hier ganz normal Langlaufen das
ist offenbar der Weg zugänglich für
Passanten für Spaziergänger
nebenan die Gleise rechts von uns
befindet sich ein kabelschachter sind
die Versorgungsleitungen drin für die
Signalstellung was sind Stromleitungen
drin da sind vermutlich sogar
funkleitung drinne also man muss hier
nur eine oder zwei Platten hochnehmen
und kommt dann frei zugänglich an die an
die Kabel dran nicht an jedem Kabel
hängt die Sicherheit des gesamten
Bahnnetzes doch die Zugänge sind leicht
und die Folgen könnten verheerend sein
Kabel ist vielleicht mal ausgetauscht
worden und nicht wieder in den
Kabelschacht zurückgelegt worden aber
öffentlich zugänglich keine Ahnung was
das für ein Kabel ist könnte mit dem mit
dem achsenmesser Zusammenhängen der da
vorne an den an den Gleisen also würde
dieses Kabel beschädigt werden würden
Fehlmeldung kommen und dadurch werden
hier die Streckensperrung ausgelöst die
Signalstellung die würden hier auf Rot
gehen und keinen Zug würde ernsthaft
mehr hier fahren können und wollen zeigt
das aber auch wie analog verwundbar wir
noch sind hier muss man nicht wirklich
viel machen und ich habe jetzt keine
Ahnung ich bin kein Elektriker ich weiß
nicht wie viel Strom da drauf ist aber
mit einer isolierten Zange könnte man
das sicherlich einfach so klappen
Heiko tegarts fordert tausende
zusätzliche Stellen für die
Bundespolizei zudem eine massive
Aufrüstung in der technischen
Überwachung zum Beispiel durch Drohnen
also hier ist die Bahn am Zug hier muss
die Bahn auch was machen technisch
sichern durch Sensortechnik meinetwegen
durch Kameras aber nichtsdestotrotz wenn
was auslöst muss ja auch jemand her und
schauen was passiert hier gerade
ohne die Bahn sind wir aufgeschmissen
33.400 km Streckennetz ziehen sich quer
durch Deutschland
2021 transportierte die Bahn 2,9
Milliarden Menschen plus knapp 227
Millionen Tonnen Güter
Deutschland ist bei den kritischen
Infrastrukturen sehr verwundbar das
haben die Angriffe auf die Bahn am 8
Oktober gezeigt der Politiker und
Sicherheitsexperte Roderich Kiesewetter
kritisiert das seit vielen Jahren bei
der Bahn Sabotage gibt er der Bahn eine
Mitschuld wir können nicht alles
schützen wir müssen uns auch bewusst
sein dass wir weiter solche Angriffe
erleben werden vielleicht auch ganz
unvorhergesehene Dinge und deshalb kommt
darauf an dass die Strukturen die
angegriffen werden sich auch selber
schützen ganz konkretes Beispiel bis
Mitte Oktober war bei der Bahn ein
Dokument im Netz wo alle kritische
Infrastrukturen abgerufen werden konnten
und ein Video wo jemand mit fröhlicher
Stimme erklärt hat an welchen wichtigen
Weichen und kritischen Punkten man
vorbeigefahren ist ein Lehrbuch für die
Vorbereitung von Anschlägen also es
kommt auch sehr stark darauf an die
unnötige Transparenz in manchen
Bereichen zurückzufahren die
eisenbahn-agentur der EU fordert seit
über 20 Jahren eine bessere Vorbereitung
unvorhersehbare Ereignisse passiert ist
seitdem laut Experten zu wenig was sagt
die Bahn selbst zu den Vorwürfen wir
können mehr tun wir werden auch mehr tun
wir werden einmal personell etwas tun
nämlich zusätzlich zu den DB eigenen
Sicherheitskräften die zusammen mit der
Bundespolizei für Sicherheit sorgen noch
mehr DB Kräfte aufbieten und zum anderen
auch technisch wir werden die Zahl der
Kabel die für Redundanzen also für
Rückfall Ebenen sorgen noch erhöhen
indem wir zum Beispiel freie Kapazitäten
bei den Kabelkanälen nutzen es gibt in
Frankreich als auch in Norwegen
eingezäunte Bahnstrecken das gibt es in
Deutschland nicht warum wir haben ja
einen sehr dichtes Netz auch in der
Region auch in der Fläche mit
Bahnübergängen mit ebenerdigen ähm
gleisführungen das kann man nicht rund
um die Uhr bewachen das kann man auch
nicht komplett einzahlen dieser botage
bei der Bahn ein Warnsignal das zeigt
wie verwundbar wir sind welch großer
Schaden für unsere Fluggesellschaft mit
geringen Mitteln zu erreichen ist schon
früher gab es solche Warnsignale die
kritische infrastrukturgerät als
Angriffsziel immer wieder in den Fokus
22 Mai 2021 Brandanschlag auf 50
Stromkabel in München
150 Trafostationen fallen aus 24 Oktober
2022 ein Hackerangriff legt die
Verwaltung im Rhein-Pfalz-Kreis am
Standort Ludwigshafen
und auch hier hat man das erlebt Templin
in Brandenburg eine 16000 Einwohner
Kleinstadt nicht weit von Berlin kürzere
Stromausfälle kennt man hier wie überall
doch 2019 erlebt Bürgermeister Detlef
tammert etwas das er so nicht erwartet
hatte offenbar durch einen Hackerangriff
liegt die ganze Verwaltung lahm nichts
geht mehr im Rathaus tagelang Tabak ist
alarmiert
ging das vor Augen geführt wie
verwundbar man im Zweifel ist und dann
auch machtlos war doch ein ziemlich
Einschnitt man hat dann ungefähr drei
Wochen die brauchen wieder ins normale
Leben zurückzukommen und die normalen
Abläufe am Start zu haben und ich habe
schon bisschen ein mulmiges Gefühl wenn
man das sich für ganz Deutschland
vorstellt wenn Großteil auch der
Rechnerkapazitäten ausfällt ob es nun
ein Hackerangriff ist oder begründet ist
in einem großflächigen Blackout wie sehr
am 2019 denken müssen als jetzt von dem
Sabotage sagt auf die Pipelines und die
Deutsche Bank erfahren haben zwei Kabel
werden durchgeschnitten und 100000
Menschen werden in ihrem normalen
Tagesablauf gestört kommen nicht zur
Arbeit können ihre Familien nicht
besuchen können die Kinder nicht abholen
also es ist doch so eine kalte Dusche
dass man sieht Vorsicht ist erforderlich
und wir sind auf seine auf solche
Situationen in Deutschland glaube ich
sehr schlecht vorbereitet als in Templin
der Strom zurück ist geht es schnell
wieder in den Alltag über eine neue
Schutzsoftware das war's aktuelle
Umfragen zeigen einem Großteil der
deutschen Kommunen fehlt ein Notfallplan
Templin will das nun ändern eine
Sicherheitsübung soll die Abläufe testen
und Strukturen für den Notfall schaffen
das Szenario ein flächendeckender
Stromausfall über mehrere Stunden bis
Tage
wir haben jetzt über Fehlstelle
eingerichtet die Aufnahme der Arbeit
alleine bin und starken Winter haben
zwei Tage vielleicht ohne Strom und die
Bäume dazwischen krachen die Rechner
gehen nicht das war eben analog in der
Lage sein müssen die Grundversorgung
aufrecht zu halten das Besondere an
Templin die Stadt erstreckt sich über
knapp 380 Quadratkilometer und ist damit
der Fläche nach die acht größte Stadt
Deutschlands die Wege zwischen den
einzelnen Ortsteilen sind weit oft
liegen bis zu einer Stunde Autofahrt
zwischen ihnen im Falle eines
Stromausfalls wird das zum Problem
wenn die Kommunikation ausfällt wir
gehen davon aus nach 24 Stunden die
Handynetze je nachdem wie stark die dann
letztendlich beansprucht werden in
Deutschland geht man zwar davon aus sie
können im theoretisch länger laufen aber
im Regelfall kommt die Angst dazu man
möchte die liebsten noch schnell
erreichen man schafft es nicht man
schickt SMS man schickt WhatsApp oder
dergleichen
die Information nicht mehr an wir haben
ja bisher diese Erfahrung gemacht durch
die Wetterlage durch die Sturmschäden da
können wir aus Erfahrung sprechen aber
durch so ein Blackout
das ist schwierig welche Szenarien uns
da wirklich erwarten wie gut kann eine
Kommune im Notfall agieren Templin will
es testen
kritische Infrastrukturen sind die
Einrichtungen die für die
Aufrechterhaltung des Lebens
unerlässlich sind in den meisten
deutschen Städten sind sie wie in
Templin über das ganze Stadtgebiet
verteilt zu ihnen zählen die Bereiche
Energieversorgung Krankenhäuser und
Rettungsdienste Banken Verwaltung
Lebensmittelhändler Bahnhöfe
Telekommunikation und Wasserwerke
wenn an einer Stelle angegriffen wird
hat dies oft weitreichende Auswirkungen
warnt peter Neumann Experte für Daten
und Informationssicherheit es ist
natürlich so dass Infrastruktur
miteinander verbunden sind die für das
Funktionieren unsere Gesellschaft
notwendig sind und das heißt dass man
eben schon diesen Kaskade Effekt sehen
könnte wo dann sozusagen die Zerstörung
einer Infrastruktur andere
Infrastrukturen betrifft und dann
möglicherweise Blackouts oder Probleme
in anderen Infrastrukturen verursacht in
der Nacht zum 26 September kommt es zum
Sabotageakt auf die beiden Gaspipelines
Nord Stream 1 und 2
unterirdische Detonationen und mehrere
Lex sorgen dafür dass kein Gas mehr nach
Deutschland fließen kann Gas aus
Norwegen wird daher immer wichtiger
verstärktes Militär soll dafür sorgen
die Pipelines zu schützen
normalerweise helfen wir bei Erdrutschen
oder suchen vermisste das hier ist schon
eine ganz andere Sache ein sehr ernster
Auftrag da macht man sich schon seine
Gedanken was es eigentlich bedeutet hier
aufzupassen
das Sicherheitsrisiko in Norwegen ist
gestiegen die Angst vor einem ähnlichen
Anschlag auf norwegische Pipelines ist
groß
strategischen Hotspot geworden wir sind
wohl das wichtigste Ziel in dieser Art
von Grauzonen kriegsführungen weil wir
so stark zur europäischen
Energieversorgung beitragen vor allem
auf der Nordsee
wer hinter dem Angriff auf Nord Stream
steckt ist nicht bewiesen Spekulationen
um eine russische Beteiligung kursieren
das ist natürlich
auch ein ziemliches Statement gewesen
und aufgrund dieses Anschlags auf die
Pipeline kann glaube ich keiner mehr
bestreiten dass es wirklich im Kontext
dieses Konfliktes war das war kein
Unfall das war ein absichtlicher
Anschlag im Kontext dieses Konfliktes
und das war etwas wo ganz wenige Leute
gedacht haben dass das überhaupt möglich
ist
der Angriff auf die Pipelines im Meer
war spektakulär aber so viel braucht es
gar nicht um viel Schaden anzurichten
München im Mai 2021 ein Brandanschlag
löst einen folgenschweren Blackout aus
50 Stromkabel werden vollständig
zerstört rund 20.000 Haushalte müssen
ohne stromauskommen Büros liegen lahm
der öffentliche Nahverkehr funktioniert
nur eingeschränkt auch unsere
Stromversorgung ist verwundbar ein
flächendeckender Schutz der Leitungen
fast unmöglich
die Firma Transnet bW ist einer der vier
deutschen Übertragungsnetzbetreiber sie
sind deutschlandweit für den
Stromtransport vom Erzeuger zuständig
und für eine gleichmäßige Auslastung der
Stromnetze eine Schaltstelle also und
eine gut geschützte Anlage hier kommt
nur selten jemand hinein gerade in der
aktuellen Sicherheitslage Chef des
Netzbetriebs bei Transnet bW ist Jens
lang Becker er ist für die
Stromübertragung im gesamten Südwesten
Deutschlands verantwortlich und bereit
mit uns zu reden das sieht aus wie bei
der Nase also in der Mitte im Netz
Abbild unseres Transportnetzes
Umspannwerke also die die Anlagen die
wir in Baden-Württemberg betreiben wo
wir Energie austauschen mit
nachbarnetzen und die Linien dazwischen
repräsentieren praktisch unsere Leitung
Aussicht der Übertragungsnetzbetreiber
könnte es in diesem Winter zu Strom
Ausfällen kommen wenn etwa eine
gasmangelage entsteht und die
Atomkraftwerke in Frankreich gleich
weiterhin zu wenig Energie produzieren
das wichtigste ist ja an der Stelle dass
man findet dass es irgendwie
unkontrolliert wird das ist aber unser
Ziel hier an der Stelle darauf
vorbereitet zu sein auch wenn ich
eigentlich erwarten würde das ist
ja nur passieren kann wenn wirklich
viele viele Faktoren zusammenkommen
sie stoppen so ein bisschen sie zögern
so ein bisschen wenn Sie das sagen
das muss klar sein es gibt
Szenarien die eintreten können bei denen
es tatsächlich nicht also wirklich
gezwungen sind dann auch Kunden in der
versorgungsunterbrechen
und alles belastet einen natürlich
trotzdem müssen wir uns darauf
vorbereiten und einfach dann zu
verhindern dass es irgendwie
unkontrolliert
hat zu größeren Störungen kommt im
Oktober 2022 warnt das Bundeskriminalamt
in einem Schreiben an
Wirtschaftsvertreter vor weiteren
Sabotageakten in Deutschland auch auf
Gas und Stromleitungen nach dem Angriff
auf Nord Stream 1 und 2 hat Transnet BW
umgehend reagiert und Sicherheitsübungen
nochmals verstärkt ich glaube mein
erster Gedanke war echt
Entsetzen weil es was ist was man in
Deutschland viele Jahrzehnte lang nicht
mehr erlebt haben Anschläge gegen
Infrastruktur ist glaube ich sehr sehr
lange her dass wir sowas in Deutschland
erlebt haben
und insofern ist war was was glaube ich
vorher nicht wirklich so richtig
vorstellbar war wie groß ist eigentlich
die Angst sie haben werden von über Nord
streamen gesprochen vor möglichen
Sabotage Akten auch auf Stromleitungen
in Deutschland
also die Lagerungen die Behörden
einschätzen wie kritisiert einschätzen
1,72 Millionen Kilometer Länge misst das
deutsche Stromnetz es rund um die Uhr zu
schützen ist unmöglich Schwankungen im
Stromverbrauch oder auch in der
Stromverteilung können die vier
Netzbetreiber zu einem Teil ausgleichen
doch auf größere oder komplette Ausfälle
durch Einwirkung von außen sind sie
nicht vorbereitet die Folgen wären fatal
also ich denke die Sicherheitslage hat
sich grundsätzlich verändert wir müssen
uns dran gewöhnen dass es eine Art
Hybride Kriegsführung gibt was bedeutet
für z.B nicht staatliche feindliche
Akteure wie z.B Russland geht es eben
nicht nur darum den Krieg auf dem
Schlachtfeld zu gewinnen den kriegt
militärisch zu gewinnen sondern da
werden alle Instrumente der staatlichen
Macht eingesetzt und da wird eben auch
hinter den Linien angegriffen und nicht
nur militärisch sondern auch politisch
und psychologisch es geht darum die
Stimmung hier im Land den politischen
Willen sich an diesem Konflikt zu
beteiligen zu manipulieren zurück in
Templin erst im September hatte der
deutsche Städte und Gemeindebund vor
möglichen blackout-szenarien gewarnt das
beschäftigt die Menschen bereiten sie
sich dann irgendeinerweise irgendwie
besonders vor Holz Holz ein bisschen
unabhängiger
als vom Gasöl
vor was genau haben sie da Angst ich
meine wenn ich mal zu Hause dann kein
Strom mehr habe oder kein Gas dann wird
es bei uns sehr kritisch weil ich muss
jetzt sozusagen mein Mann ist
querschnittsgelähmt Rollstuhlfahrer und
wenn bei uns die Heizung oder der Strom
ausfällt dann sind wir schon sehr
aufgeschmissen das hatten wir im letzten
Jahr schon
da ist sein Bett dann ausgefallen wir
kann das Bett nicht mehr hoch runter
stellen das ist nur eine Kleinigkeit
aber wenn große Firmen ausfallen dann
ist das schon sehr bedenklich also wenn
nur der Strom weggeht
dann ist ja schon alles
dann hast du gar nichts keine Heizung
kein Wasser kein nichts
und sich so vorbereiten dass man
wirklich darum gewappnet ist kann man
gar nicht
in Templin versorgen 20 Wasserwerke eine
Fläche von fast 1000 Quadratkilometer
hier aus dem größten Wasserwerk werden
am Tag 1000 bis 1500 Kubikmeter Wasser
ins Versorgungsnetz befördert das Netz
selber ist gut gesichert davon gehen Sie
hier zumindest aus doch ohne Strom
bliebe jede Wohnung auch ohne Wasser ein
möglicher Blackout ist daher auch hier
ein Thema
bisher sind es eher Ausfälle in
einzelnen kleinen Bereichen sozusagen
die auf jeden Fall händelbar schon immer
waren momentan ja werden Fragen gestellt
danach eine ganze Woche in Stromausfall
kompensieren zu können wie lange wäre es
denn überhaupt möglich trotzdem für die
für die Wasserversorgung gewappnet zu
sein glaube das war aus meiner Sicht im
Moment die die Woche schaffen würden
was viele vergessen Abwasser wird durch
Pumpen gesteuert und in Kläranlagen
geführt dies ist ohne Strom ebenfalls
nicht mehr möglich ein Ausfall hätte
verheerende Folgen
wann würde es gefährlich werden für
Umwelt und Mensch wenn hier gar keine
Aufbereitung mehr stattfindet wir haben
ja schon alleine in freigeschalteten
Anlagen die
Siebung und die der Sandfang und alleine
wenn die ganzen Feststoffe irgendwie in
die Umwelt gelangen durch Überlauf oder
hier die Biologie stirbt und wir sagen
ungeklärtes Wasser würde irgendwo in die
Natur wieder gelangen konnte sofort denn
die Umwelt schieben
wird kein Sauerstoff mehr zugefügt würde
die biologische Reinigung ausfallen die
Kläranlage könnte schon nach wenigen
Stunden kippen
ich denke es gibt kritische
Infrastrukturen dabei ist man da gibt es
gewisse vulnerabilitäten
Verwundbarkeiten wie zum Beispiel im
cyberbereich der wurde auch ein bisschen
was gemacht und besonders die größeren
Unternehmen sind ganz gut geschützt aber
es gibt eben auch viele Verwundbarkeiten
in anderen kritischen Infrastrukturen wo
fast gar nichts gemacht wurde ich nenne
Energie ich nenne Wasser Verkehr zum
Beispiel da ist sehr wenig passiert was
wahrscheinlich damit zu tun hat sie dass
wir uns in Sicherheit gewogen haben
dabei können die Auswirkungen eines
Angriffs gerade für die schwächsten
schwerwiegend sein das alten und
Pflegeheim Senioren Landsitz in Templin
ist ein Ort an dem die Menschen wie ein
kaum einem anderen auf Hilfe angewiesen
sind und auf verlässliche Strukturen die
angespannte Lage ist auch hier Thema
BewohnerInnen und Pflegerinnen machen
sich Sorgen
alles auf einmal hat wir alles so hinter
uns haben erst mit Corona denn jetzt mit
dem Krieg und jetzt die Angst dass wir
bald kein Strom mehr haben es geht im
Winter zu es ist schon um viel dunkel
und wenn sie dann kein Licht mehr haben
na dann laufen sie ja irgendwie so das
sind ja gar nicht was wohin sie sollen
allerdings ist man ja dran gewöhnt das
Fernsehen anzumachen
Abendbrot gegessen im Winter nachher das
Fernsehen ist eben das was wir haben
muss oder das Radio nehmen
wie viel vom Strom abhängt zeigt sich
oft erst wenn er ausbleibt
[Musik]
weiß er hier gibt es ein
Notstromaggregat natürlich wegen all
diesen Einrichtungen aber man merkt ja
endlich erst wieder so richtig ich weiß
wie irgendwann hatten wir das mal für
eine Stunde wo man dann denkt alberter
Weise auch gerade Kaffee kochen geht da
nicht nimmst ein Wasserkocher oder so
nee geht ja auch nicht hat braucht ja
auch Strom und also die Dinge
bis zu 104 pflegebedürftige Menschen
werden hier rund um die Uhr versorgt die
Einrichtung ist in privater Hand im
Notfall ist Betreiber Jacques
Brandenburger dafür verantwortlich den
täglichen Pflegeablauf aufrecht zu
erhalten
wir würden reduzieren die frische wir
nehmen denn mehr Dosen mehr
Fertiggerichte die dann eben mit
Heißwasser das war selber mit unserem
eigenen Gas erhitzen
das würde für welchen Zeitraum reichen
anderthalb zwei Monate anderthalb zwei
Monate nur dafür wann würde es anfangen
bedrohlich zu werden für die Einrichtung
für ihre Bewohner wenn jetzt der Strom
ausfallen würde ja natürlich überall da
wo in der medizinischen Versorgung
Elektrizität erforderlich ist und dann
natürlich unser Notstromaggregat
irgendwann ein Ende hat in der
verbrauchssituation das kann 8 oder 14
oder auf 30 Tage erweitert werden aber
darüber hinaus kann man schwer heute
davon ausgehen
80% der kritischen Infrastruktur werden
von privaten Unternehmen betrieben
Notfallpläne liegen in Ihrer
Verantwortung Transnet BW war bisher
komplett in öffentlicher Hand jetzt
stehen 49,9% zum Verkauf ja wir finden
uns hier in einem Besprechungszimmer was
aber wenn es notwendig wäre auch als
krisenraum gehen würde würde hier
tatsächlich dann auf der Krisenstab der
Transnet BW sitzen und uns durch die
Krise führen
Jens lang Becker sieht auch klar Politik
und Gesellschaft in der Pflicht die
Entscheidung sich tatsächlich
gesellschaftlich politisch
weil es ist eine Frage sozusagen auch
was wollen wir uns dort leisten wie
teuer darf es sein wie sicher muss es
sein
und insofern ja ist das praktisch meine
ich eine Entscheidung die sozusagen
Gesellschaft gesamt treffen muss und die
nicht wie als übertragungsbetreiber
irgendwie alleine treffen könnten
sie sehen also Defizite
das kann ich nicht beurteilen momentan
das heißt sie würden nicht so weit gehen
und sagen es gibt da möglicherweise noch
Missstände wo man besser werden kann im
Hinblick auf die Sicherheit ich werde
dazu nichts sagen
wir sind mit Manuel artuch von der AG
kritis verabredet einer
Arbeitsgemeinschaft in der sich
unabhängige Fachleute für mehr
Sicherheit in kritischen Infrastrukturen
stark machen atuk hat als Gründer und
Sprecher schon bei der Anhörung im
Bundestag zum aktuellen
it-sicherheitsgesetz Kritik an der
unzureichenden Strategie der Politik
geübt die IT-Sicherheit in Deutschland
bleibt aus seiner Sicht auf der Strecke
wir sollten vielleicht langsam mal
anfangen tatsächlich defensiv zu agieren
dass wir den Schutzgitter
Infrastrukturen als Primärziel
definieren und sagen nicht die Befugnis
Erweiterung für Sicherheitsbehörden und
Geheimdienste sind relevant sondern
tatsächlich die Versorgungssicherheit
der Bevölkerung denn die stellt sich ja
eigentlich die Frage kommt morgen noch
Strom und Wasser aus der Leitung und da
sollte sowohl das Innenministerium als
auch die Regierung ja sagen können Sie
das mal so ein bisschen konkretieren was
sind genau die Versäumnisse und die
Fehler auf Seiten der
Bundesinnenministerium
wenn wir von den 10.500 Kommunen
irgendwie gefühlt die Hälfte haben die
archäologisch wertvolle Betriebssysteme
einsetzen aber nicht auf dem aktuellen
it-sicherheitsstand sind dann ist das ja
auch eine gewisse Aussagekraft wie
vulnerabel wir sind das ist kein guter
Zustand dann müssen wir dahin gehen und
Aufräumen klar
gerne hätten wir bundesinnenministerin
Nancy fazer mit diesen Forderungen
konfrontiert ein Interview lehnt ihre
Pressestelle trotz mehrmaliger Nachfrage
ab und verweist auf ihre Äußerungen bei
einer Pressekonferenz in Leipzig
Betreiber kritischer Infrastruktur
müssen sich kümmern wir haben seit dem
24 Februar seitdem furchtbaren
kriegsangriff Putins in der Ukraine die
Betreiberinnen und Betreiber kritische
Infrastruktur aufgefordert die
entsprechenden Schutzmaßnahmen
vorzugehen das ist deren Aufgaben die
gerade die privaten da haben wir ja
keinen direkten Einfluss drauf aber wir
können natürlich Anforderungen auch an
Sicherheit formulieren deswegen machen
wir das jetzt auch ein gesetzesformen
ein konkretes Datum für dieses Gesetz
nennt die Ministerin nicht schriftlich
bestätigt dass Innenministerium und die
Haltung dass die Hauptlast bei den
privaten Anbietern liege
es ist grundsätzlich Aufgabe der
Betreiber kritischer Infrastrukturen
seines Unternehmen oder Behörden für
einen sicheren und zuverlässigen Betrieb
Ihrer Anlagen und Einrichtungen zu
sorgen die Nachfrage ob die
Bundesregierung sich nicht selbst
stärker engagieren müsste und ob die
massiven Kosten der geforderten
Investitionen auch komplett von den
privaten Betreibern finanziert werden
sollen beantwortet das Ministerium nicht
auch die Gemeinden und Städte sind
aufgefordert sich selbst vorzubereiten
Sicherheitsübung in Templin 20
Einsatzkräfte der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr
üben an diesem Abend ziel ist eine
Notfallplan aufzustellen für eine
mögliche Katastrophe wie einen Blackout
stelle ich mal so ein bisschen auf dem
Rasen so halt mit drauf ja das war den
den Stromerzeuger dann gleich mit runter
nehmen können
mit Hilfe von Generatoren werden
Treibstofftanks wie dieser zu
notfalltankstellen die Reserven dienen
vorrangig den Rettungsdiensten im
Notfall gilt es sie zu schützen je
nachdem polizeiordnungsamt würde dann
hier mit unterstützen und die Tankstelle
halt quasi mit bewachen dann halt ja
weil die Scheiße gehen vielleicht nicht
gerade beim ersten Tag wieder
Bürgermeister sagt aber so zweiten
dritten Tag wenn so langsam die Panik
losgeht
wo es dann in Richtung geht
Bürgermeister Detlef Tabbert will die
Notfallpläne weiter ausbauen die
kritische Infrastruktur so gut es geht
für den Ernstfall vorbereiten und er
will seine Bürger für das Thema
sensibilisieren ohne Panik all das
vermisste auch aus Berlin
meines Erachtens bisher gnadenlos
versäumt da eine vernünftige
Kommunikation mit der Bevölkerung auf
dem Weg zu bringen das schlimmste ist ja
wenn Bürger in der Situation nicht
wissen wo habe ich einen Ansprechpartner
oder wie kann ich mich dort Verhalten
Kommunen und Betreiber kritischer
Infrastrukturen fühlen sich allein
gelassen trotz erhöhter Gefährdungslage
Warnsignale nehmen zu Sabotage Akte
häufen sich wir haben aber offenbar
keinen gemeinsamen Plan klare Strukturen
fehlen im Notfall kann das zur
Katastrophe führen
[Musik]